québec sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans libre et vous
l'émission littéraire qui par des livres
pour aller vers vous c'est avec vous que
nous allons réfléchir à une question
aujourd'hui une question que vous êtes
sûrement poser dans les moments de
mélancolie et de tristesse ou de douleur
la littérature et la philosophie
peuvent-elles nous consoler les livres
et ceux qui les écrivent ont-ils de
pouvoir de nous faire aller mieux
c'est avec une romancière est un
philosophe que nous allons réfléchir à
cette question aujourd'hui
la romancière s'appelle judith brouste
elle publie chez gallimard l'enfance
futur dans lequel elle s'adresse à la
petite fille qualité et qui mal récit
biographique et récits de guerre avant
de l'accueillir la parole est un
philosophe qui cherche sans cesse les
mots les plus justes pour décrire ce qui
lui vit il s'est fait connaître avec son
petit traité des grandes vertus publié
en 1995 dans lequel il présente la
philosophie comme un véritable art de
vivre et après avoir écrit sur le
bonheur l'érotisme le désespoir mais
aussi le capitalisme il publie
aujourd'hui l'inconsolable un recueil de
textes brefs et accessible qui interroge
la fonction même de la philosophie en
cas de grande tempête
bonjour andré comte sponville bonjour
bienvenue dans livres et vous merci
est-ce que les bibliothèques en
l'occurrence la nex de la bibliothèque
du sénat vous rassure où vous vous
angoisse non ça me fait rêver
je rêverais d'avoir ça chez moi même un
tout petit bout de ça me suffirait
nantes est un endroit on envie de
travailler et je crois qu'au fond c'est
les sa lé livre d autres donne envie de
travailler
on en fait un cadre formidable et vous
travaillez à proximité des livres des
autres justement à ça dépend c'est vous
parce que le cas à paris j'ai très peu
de place et donc alors que mes livres
sont surtout dans une maison que j'ai en
normandie où je passe cinq mois par an
et donc à paris lille c'est pas mal je
m'oblige à travailler sans avoir tous
les livres autour de moi ce qui m'a un
peu libéré de dd un peu d'éthique
universitaire qui consiste à mettre 3
référente et qu'on croit avoir quitté
personnel pour montrer que c'est pas
tout à fait personnel voilà mais en même
temps j'aime mieux être en normandie où
j'ai dans mon bureau
quelques centaines de livres vous
écrivez depuis un moment vous avez
publié de nombreux ouvrages de l'est dit
celui qui vous a fait connaître qui
s'est beaucoup vendu s'appelait petit
traité des grandes vertus
il faut imaginer pour ceux qui ne savent
pas ou qui n'étaient pas en 1995 le
livre a rencontré un succès phénoménal
c'était le premier livre de philosophie
qui se vendait autant à ce moment là
mille trois cent mille exemplaires en
grande forme à 100 les poches mes amis
me disent quand elle n'était jamais
arrivé à brens est peut-être arrivé
depuis je ne sais pas les chiffres les
plus récents des des collègues c'est
jeudi
oui c'est un succès hors norme qui
s'explique au moins en partie parce que
ça peut une rencontre entre un auteur et
une génération la sienne en l'occurrence
c'est à dire que les soixante huitards
je fais partie qui avait voulu se passer
de toute morale il est interdit
d'interdire jouissons sans temps mort
vivons sans entraves ou l'inversé ils
ont fait des enfants
et quand on a des enfants on se rend
compte qu'il n'est pas interdit
d'interdire qu'il est même en toute
rigueur interdit de ne pas interdire il
ya des choses qu'il faut interdire ya
pas de temps mort cela dit quand on a
des enfants n'y a pas beaucoup de temps
morts c'est vrai qu'il faut transmettre
des valeurs transmettre une morale et
donc les soixante huitards qui est un
peu démunis parce que dans leur jeunesse
ils avaient comme moi d'ailleurs cracher
sur la vieille morale judéo-chrétienne
toujours réputé castratrice
culpabilisatrice
et puis tout d'un coup il ya quelqu un
de leurs générations qui se met à parler
de morale à reprendre ce vieux mot
obsolète de deux vertus et je crois que
cette rencontre là a expliqué une bonne
partie du succès effectivement hors
norme de ce livre et c'était une manière
aussi de montrer peut-être de manière
involontaire que ce qu'on appelle la
philosophie et qu'on associe à une
discipline académique universitaire
souvent jargonnante dans des les
bibliothèques pléiade pouvait être
accessible à tout le monde
oui ça fait partie de mon combat mais
déjà dans mes livres précédents bien sûr
alors c'est un peu la tradition
française en philosophie bergson l'a dit
un fidèle français s'adressent non pas à
ses collègues mais à l'humanité des 10es
personne et c'est vrai quand on prend
les plus grands philosophes français en
commençant par les premiers montaigne
descartes pascal ils écrivent
non pas pour leurs collègues d'ailleurs
ils n'ont pas ils écrivent pour nous le
grand public décidé d'écarter free le
discours de méthode en français c'est
pour que même les femmes puissent le
lire disait-il à l'époque et à l'époque
les femmes ne faisait pas d'étude s'ils
voulaient alors qu'un inverse prenons la
tradition allemande leibniz kant hegel
immense génie aussi ça va de soi mais ne
sont pas lisibles parle par le grand
public aux frais la crise la raison pure
à tel ou tel de vos amis qui n'es pas
philosophe il n'y comprendra rien même
si on parle français oui oui bien sûr
même perdu en français nos frais lui les
pensées de pascal les méditations
métaphysiques de descartes les essais de
montaigne
il comprendra tout l'essentiel et c'est
vrai que moi je suis pas de hiérarchie
entre ces deux traditions mais celle
dans laquelle je me sens le plus à
l'aise celle que j'avais envie de
prolonger
c'est en effet la tradition française ce
que nietzsche puis deux allemands mais
qu'ils préféraient les penseurs français
ce que nie chapelet la belle clarté
française et j'ai voulu renouer en effet
après des années de penser quand même
très difficile et zargo nantes un dans
ma jeunesse pensons à derrida lacan
deleuze dans une moindre mesure
j'ai voulu renouer en effet avec cette
belle clarté et française vous avez un
cursus scolaire classique et prestigieux
en france est passé par l'école normale
supérieure quand vous décidé d'écrire un
livre de philosophie est ce que c'est
une manière de montrer que la
philosophie n'est pas qu'une discipline
qu'on étudie mais aussi alors peut-être
l'expression est elle un peu galvaudé
peut-être n'at-elle aucun sens de
est ce que c'est pour montrer que la
philosophie serait aussi un art de vivre
là c'est d'abord quand même un art de
penser dirais même à un travail de de
penser mais qui doivent servir à vivre
là deleuze avait raison de le disait si
vous pensez que la philosophie ne sert à
rien n'en fait pas non or à quoi
pourrait-elle servir pas à gagner de
l'argent par la fin de la politique que
16 elle sert forcément à vivre
moi je dis depuis très longtemps que
philosopher c'est penser sa vie et vivre
sa pensée mais faut ajouter très vite
que c'est un idéal on n'y arrive jamais
tout à fait parce qu'il ya toujours du
nom pensée dans toute vie et du non vécu
dedans tout penser à turin hiatus entre
les deux mais c'est vrai que l'idéal
vers quoi on tend c'est sa pensée sa vie
vivre sa pensée il est malgré tout ses
pensées c'est à dire qu' il s'agit pas
simplement d'aller au bonheur par le
plus court chemin et peut-être d'autres
voies que la philosophie la pensée n'est
digne de ce nom qu'à la condition de se
soumettre à ce que spinoza appelait la
norme de l'idée vraies données autrement
dit penser d'abord se soumettre à ce qui
paraît vrai lors la vérité on la connaît
jamais tout jamais absolument mais on en
connaît assez pour la distinguer du
mensonge de l'ignorance ou de l'illusion
ce pour quoi j'ai toujours dit que si un
philosophe a le choix entre une vérité
est un bonheur ça se peut pas tourner au
sernam il arrive que la question se pose
dans ces termes là si le philosophe a le
choix entre une vérité est un bonheur il
n'est philosophes ou digne de l'être
qu'en tant qu il choisit la vérité mais
bien souvent on tient pour la vérité ce
qui n'est qu'une opinion
or la philosophie est bien l'un verse de
l'opinion l'un vers comment savoir sur
la détient la vérité on prétend plus de
fait ils inversent de l'opinion linverse
de l'opinion ça tu appelles la science
et la philosophie n'est n'est pas une
science montrent andy plus aliments de
la ville de filles c'est une opinion
sophistiqués ils pas au sens ce qui est
du thème au centre par une chaîne stéréo
sophistiqué perfectionner très habile
etc
oui parce que dès lors qu'on n'est pas
capable de démontrer la vérité d'une
position philosophique des loques la rue
dauphine n'est pas une science et ne
sera jamais une science
on est quand même dans quelque chose qui
relève de l'opinion mais d'une opinion
travaillé réfléchi donc on peut
l'appeler autrement en vérité on
l'appelle philosophie mais le point
important c'est ça si on a le choix
entre une vérité est un bonheur on est
philosophe kant encore choisi la vérité
autrement dit
nouveau une vraie tristesse qu'une
fausse joie il s'agit pas de pensée pour
se faire plaisir pour se rassurer ou
pour se consoler d'ailleurs si
j'appelais ce livre l'inconsolable c'est
que justement l'idée que la fille soit
là pour nous consoler me paraît une idée
fausse les ouvrages que vous avez publié
le dernier compris qui s'appelle en
effet l'inconsolable et autres
impromptue aux éditions puf portent sur
des thèmes qui touchent au plus près le
lecteur des thèmes qui sont souvent
sombres par le désespoir de la
mélancolie de la tristesse du tragique
est ce que c'est parce que ce sont ces
états là qui nous font accéder à cette
vérité ces terres classées comme un
livre particulier par rapport à d'autres
livres que j'ai écrits jeu d'appeler
impromptue et c'est bien sûr un clin
d'oeil aux impromptus de deux cyber
comme vous le savez les impôts tout
joubert c'est quoi ces deux oeuvres pour
piano seul des des morceaux plutôt bref
très facile d'accès un c'est de la
musique oui facile d'accès
intimiste et d'un climat légèrement
mélancolique disant voilà ce qui
s'appelle impromptue cd texte
relativement bref très facile d'accès
c'est pas de la philosophie technique
intimiste au sens où j'y parle de moi en
tant qu'individu beaucoup plus que dans
mes livres plus technique
il ya en effet dans un climat légèrement
mélancolique parce que de fait
mélancolique je suis et donc c'est un
livre si vous voulez où je me je me
livre n'est pas un livre de confidences
et pagesjaunes a l'intimé malgré tout
j'en ai davantage sur moi en effet que
dans mes livres plus technique et ça m'a
paru important d'abord parce que ça fait
partie aussi du chantier de la
philosophie donc c'est plus proche des
essais de montaigne pour le coup que des
méditations de descartes mais aussi pour
casser une certaine image c'est à dire
que si dès que vous parlez de
philosophie qui plus est au sens
traditionnel du terme comme quête d'une
forme de sagesse filosofia engrais comme
vous le savez c'est l'amour de la
sagesse
les gens les lecteurs on parle ceux qui
ne connaissent pas personnellement ont
tendance à vous fantasmez dans le rôle
du sage ce qui est bien sûr parfaitement
grotesque j'ai toujours dit que je
n'étais pas un sage mais là dans ce
genre de texte janvier un peu de de
casser cette image là de montrer l'autre
côté du miroir est en effet comme de
fait juste quelqu'un de tempérament
plutôt mélancolique plutôt anxieux il
n'y a pas de raison de le cacher mais
vous n'avez pas attendu ce livre pour
aborder ces thèmes et c'est pour ça que
je vous posais la question le thème
espoir de la tristesse et du tragique
sont présents déposez vos premiers
livres
c'est pour ça que je voudrais savoir si
ces états la très triste on le meilleur
façon peut-être de de toucher la vérité
est ce que c'est quand on souffre qu'on
saisit le mieux de quoi la vie est faite
n'a pas quand on souffre
mais quand on n'a pas besoin d'espérer
autre chose au fond de mes premiers
livres que la paix traiter du désespoir
et de la béatitude
c'est pour critiquer les illusions de
l'espérance
ça peut arriver parce qu'on est au fond
du malheur mais au fond c'est le plus
difficile ça peut arriver parce qu on
est tellement heureux qu'on a rien
d'autre à espérer savez ce que disait
joliment paul valéry le beau c'est ce
qui désespère pas au sens où le bo en
traîtrise pas le tout mais au sens où
quand on est devant un sublime paysage
merveilleux tableau on écoute mozart
schubert
il n'y a rien d'autre à espérer n'a plus
besoin d'espérer on a tous droit
d'espérer ce que j'appelle outre parfois
line espoirs vié et je crois que tant
qu'on a besoin d'espérer quelque chose à
venir pour supporter la vie on est
séparés par là même du présent c'est à
dire de la vérité de la réalité de ce
qu'on dit
comme par ailleurs c'est vrai de
tempérament je suis quelqu'un d'un peu
j'étais un enfant g et en quelque chose
je le suis resté comme par ailleurs vers
l'âge de 17 18 ans j'ai perdu la foi
il était catholique pratiquant il a bien
fallu que j'assume ce qu'il ya au fond
de désespérance dans la condition
humaine et simplement le fait qu'on va
tous crever pour les croyantes et sans
doute différent mais une fois que vous
êtes athée que vous pensez qu'il n'y a
rien après la mort il y a en effet
quelque chose de désespérant dans la
condition humaine idia de l'inconsolable
dans nos existences et je crois qu'il
faut l'assumer pas du tout pour se
morfondre dans le malheur mais au
contraire pour prendre la vie à bras le
corps je crois qu'on sera d'autant plus
capables d'aimer la vie ce qui est la
seule vraie sagesse qu'on acceptera il y
en elle une part d'un console ah ben si
au contraire pour supporter la vie on a
besoin soit d'espérer une autre vie soit
de trouver des consolations facile pour
supporter celle ci pour moi ça ne relève
pas de la philosophie en tout cas ça ne
relève pas de la mienne mais ça demande
beaucoup de courage d'arriver à avoir la
vie pour ce qu'elle est c'est à dire un
moment qui va finir après laquelle il
n'y a rien d'autre
sans dieu sans espoir et accepter cette
part inconsolable beaucoup de courage ne
constitue pas pour écouter ce que disait
camus joliment dans le mythe de sisyphe
il est impossible de penser l'absurde
sans avoir envie d'écrire un traité du
bonheur c'est justement parce qu'on
pense qu'il n'y a rien après l'avis que
on envie de vivre cette vie si le plus
intensément le plus joyeusement possible
et donc moi je crois au contraire que
l'athéisme est une leçon de joie
paradoxalement pas ça veut dire qu'on ne
va pas attendre d'être mort si je dire
pour commencer à être heureux c'est
blaise pascal que j'adore par ailleurs
mais très croyants pour le coup une à
suivre écrit dans les pensées il n'est
de bonheur dans cette vie que dans
l'espérance d'une autre jeu autrement
dit c'est fou le seul bonheur dans cette
vie c'est d'espérer une vie après la
mort moi j'ai envie de dire à pascal
écoute mon dieu je vais pas attendre
d'être mort pour commencer à être
heureux et donc il faut à la fois
assumer cette dimension de désespoir
d'un consommables qui fait partie de la
condition humaine
mais pas du tout pour s'enfoncer dans la
tristesse au contraire pour en sortir
et pourquoi dans ce cas vous tourner
vers une forme d'écriture qui est celle
de la philosophie pourquoi pas la poésie
la littérature d'autres formes
d'écriture de sept ans contre 2,7
inconsolable mais quand j'étais très
jeune je voulais être écrivain préserver
12 13 ans jouent les écrivains comme à
l'époque je ne faisais que des romans je
voulais être romancier et donc après la
grecque de philo il était temps de se
mettre à écrire sérieusement j'ai
commencé à écrire des textes tantôt
philosophique tantôt littéraire des
poèmes des nouvelles quelques débuts de
roman est par ailleurs des aphorismes
des articles de philo et j'ai découvert
très vite que tout ce que je faisais en
matière de littérature était d'une
infinie tristesse et mélancolie prenait
le dessus alors qu'un inverse quand sud
est de la philosophie
il y avait une espèce de vivacité
tonique de deux joie parfois d'alacrité
et non le fut dit mieux vaut aller du
côté où il ya de la lumière je n'ai pas
eut ressenti le besoin de me morfondre
dans ma propre mélancolie que je ne
connais que trop alors c'est pas absurde
de ces pannes d'étonnement parce qu'au
fond la littérature et plus près de l'un
est plus proche de l'individu que nous
sommes que la philosophie parce que
justement fils de fait ces pensées sa
vie mais ses pensées et donc lakhlifi
crée une distance qui pour moi est assez
heureuse parce qu'elle met le moal égaux
à distance elle permet de prendre un
petit peu de recul autrement dit quand
je suis triste
si je fais de la littérature des
littératures ce rac triste si j'essaye
de penser la ville
et et de la tristesse ça ne fera pas
triste parce que la vérité de la
tristesse n'est pas triste et c'est ça
au fond le miracle de la philosophie
vous savez je lui en parle dans le
premier texte nous avons ma femme et moi
perdu notre premier enfant une petite
fille qui est morte à six semaines d'une
méningite foudroyante dans l'immensité
du chagrin qui était le nôtre le mien en
l'occurrence était incapable de lire les
fils et sa fille j'avais dit ça à mon
prof de cannes qui était devenu un ami
andré p c'est que tu sèmes les
philosophes ne tombent tous des mains
sauf spinoza et personne n'avait dit
c'est normal parce que spinoza d'hui
n'essayez pas de te consoler on m'a dit
voilà moi je n'aime pas les philosophes
qui console qui vous explique que qu'on
a tort de souffrir ou d'être malheureux
mais quand la souffrance et là il s'agit
pas d'avoir raison tout alors que la
souffrance est là j'aime les philosophes
qui est aviv et pour aider à vivre il
faut accepter que la souffrance voilà
quand il est là il faut accepter ce que
j'appelle la part d'un consommables de
la condition humaine
mais encore une fois pas du tout pour se
morfondre dans la mélancolie mais au
contraire pour en sortir spinoza lui dit
combattre la mélancolie ça fait partie
des tâches de la philosophie est comme
moi je suis ta mélancolique vous avez
vraiment besoin de philosopher mais vous
dites en même temps en décrivant cet
épisode atroces de la mort de votre
propre enfant que rien ne pouvez vous
consoler surtout pas les philosophes
surtout pas l'écriture si ce n'est la
joie de l'une de vos connaissances
d'être la seule personne qui n'essayait
pas de montrer de l'empathie qui
n'essayait pas de de montrer qu'elle est
et qu'il était aussi triste que vous eh
bien c'est la seule personne qui pouvait
vous apporter du réconfort
oui c'est vrai parce que la vérité moi
c'est que je veux on ne peut consoler
personnes qui souffrent vraiment peu
consolé un enfant qui s'était mal une
feinte câlins bisous me fait penser à
autre chose mais un enfant qui va mourir
à l'hôpital
comment vous allez le consoler les
parents de cet enfant comment vous allez
les consoler on ne peut pas et si bien
que nous avons perdu sept enfants mes
proches souffrait avec moi mais ça
n'était pas une consolation à limite son
chagrin s'ajoutaient aux miens alors
qu'un de mes amis un ami peintre
l'occurrence que j'étais allé voir il
peignait dehors c'est un paysagiste j'ai
passé trois quatre heures avec lui le
regard des peintres
il a réussi à m'amuser à me parler
d'autre chose à me faire comprendre que
la joie restait possible pas pour moi à
l'époque mais il me disait tu sais moi
je vais pas faire semblant c'est pas mon
frank est morte d'ailleurs je n'en ai
pas me disait-il et comme n'avait pas
d'enfant il pouvait en parler plus
sereinement que tous mes amis père ou
mère de famille qui vivait dans
l'angoissé la possibilité que le même
grade leur arrive à eux et c'est vrai
que c'est le seul qui m'a fait du bien
simplement parce qu'il m'a offert sa
joie il m'a offert sa décontraction il
m'a offert ce son humour il m'a montré
par exemple que ça n'est pas parce que
moi j'étais à l'époque dans le chagrin
que la vie n'était plus que chagrin et
je crois qu'au fond ce n'est pas un
hymne à il a passé de me consoler et
c'est le seul qui réussit finalement à
me faire passer quelques heures
agréables
ça veut dire que le fait d'être
inconsolable n'est pas incompatible avec
le fait de connaître la joie non
d'october est plus faible et joyeux oui
je t'ai jamais tisser des proches ou
bout d'os qui se définissait lui-même
comme étant inconsolable et guette mais
j'aime bien la formule au fond je la
prendrais volontiers à mon compte parce
que tout mélancoliques ou deux fois et
comme tout le monde j'ai des moments de
gaieté et je préfère largement les
moments de gaieté au moment de tristesse
pour tous vous diriez mais je crois
qu'en effet rappelé il ya une dimension
de tempérament n'est pas tous pareils
mais moi je crois d'ailleurs clément
rosset le dit aussi très bien veut à qui
vous donnez votre deuxième chapitre sur
la joie de vivre la joie de bruit parce
que sur la 3d c'est quand même clément
rosset qui est le meilleur philosophe
tragique dans la lignée de nice et qui
justement écrit que la joie la plus pure
c'est la joie sans raison ce qu'ils
appellent la joie de vivre non pas la
joie de d'un succès d'une victoire
la simple joie d'être vivante tout en
sachant bien sûr qu'on va mourir tout en
sachant que la vie n'est que ce qu'elle
est et que la joie soit d'autant plus
intense qu'elle est plus lucide ça c'est
le secret de ce que clément appelle la
joie tragique et dans cet article sur la
joie de vivre c'est ce que j'ai voulu
essayer de comprendre et c'est un très
bel article où vous distinguer la joie
du bonheur la joie de la gaieté la joie
du plaisir on se pose quand même une
question en lisant ce texte et quand on
lit tous les philosophes qui parle de la
joie il y en a plusieurs vous citiez
spinoza clément rosset montagne l'on
parle aussi camus en parle également
quand on distingue la joie du bonheur et
quand on fait de la joie finalement le
le but même peut-être de la philosophie
de la vie on se demande mais suffit-il
de décider d'être joyeux pour le devenir
parce que c'est pas une question de
caractère
une chose est de professer la joie bien
sûr soyons joyeux mais suffit pas de le
vouloir pour y parvenir bien sûr il
suffit pas non plus deux
de le penser pour l'obtenir c'est une
leçon d'humilité je dis qu'au fond pour
ce qui est de la joie de vivre
l'exemple le plus patent c'est la joie
d'un jeune show qui vient le sa
maîtresse revient et tout d'un coup il
explose de joie
et pour le vieux philosophe c'est un peu
une semaine civilisation ça fait 40 ans
50 ans qu'on galère à faire de la
philosophie et le premier petit chien
venu nous donne des leçons de joie ville
oui ça fait partir en même temps ça fait
partie de la condition humaine notre
joie est quelque peu obscurci par la
conscience par la réflexion plus de
savoir plus de douleur que nous dit le
merveilleuse ecclésiale
mais il faut aussi savoir ça il faut
savoir que la joie ne se décide pas que
le bonheur ne se décide pas et que
d'ailleurs tout bonheur est incertain et
fugace
si on entend par bonheur comme certains
une joie constante permanente immuable
c'est ce que j'appelle la féliciter
soyons clair ça n'existe pas ou au fond
de craintes quant le dit le bonheur
c'est un idéal nom de la raison mais de
l'imagination ça veut dire tout le monde
en rêve personne ne sait exactement ce
que c'est moi je crois savoir ce que
c'est parce que ma thèse en apparence
trivial mais qui va plus loin qu'il ne
le semble
ma définition c'est que le bonheur c'est
simplement le contraire du malheur ça
change tout parce que le malheur c'est
pas un idéal de nice le nageur s'il veut
plus vous aimez le malheur c'est une
expérience on l'a vécu en tout cas moi
je les ai vécus et ceux qui sont
vraiment été malheureux au moins une
fois dans leur vie savent ce que c'est
le malheur c'est qu'en toute joie par
est immédiatement un peu si vous
réveillez le matin la joie n'est pas là
et vous savez de tours de source sûre
qu'elle ne sera pas là de la journée ni
les jours qui suivent
la joie est impossible le bonheur c'est
le contraire du malheur ça veut dire que
le bonheur c'est pas un espace de temps
où la joie serait toujours réelle c'est
un espace de temps où la joie est
continûment possible par est elle
possible vous rayer le matin la joie est
là où il n'y est pas pour moi pour tout
vous dire le matin est liée plutôt
rarement je travaille plutôt difficile
mais vous savez que je vois peut venir
qu'elle va venir sans doute dans la
journée et puis qu'elle repartira et
puis qu'elle reviendra eh bien ces longs
moments de temps où la joie est
continûment possible c'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est ce que j'appelle le
bonheur et je crois que cette rue tout
le monde appelle en vérité le bonheur
savez quand j'étais jeune
des sondages on fait encore maintenant
demande aux français et vous heureux 80%
des français répondent que oui
aujourd'hui comme il ya 20 ans sauf
qu'il ya maintenant un média n'était pas
possible
les gens mentent ils font semblant
d'être heureux pas du tout le nom de
jean êtes vous heureux alors la première
réaction c'est de te dire je suis pas
malheureux et donc je suis heureux
bref ça veut dire arrêtons de rêver un
bonheur absolu parfait qui n'existent
pas ce qu'ils appellent la féliciter
contentons nous de ces moments où la
joie est continûment possible arrêtons
de rêver que la joie soit toujours
réelles faisant en sorte qu'elle
continue à être possible alors c'est pas
un bonheur absolu tabbone relatif c'est
vrai mais qu'est ce que c'est bon ça
fait maintenant parmi tel ou tel
intellectuel me dit mais le bonheur ça
n'existe pas ma première réaction c'est
de me dire en voilà encore un qui
confondent bonheur et la féliciter de
qui n'a jamais été vraiment malheureux
ne serait ce qu'une fois dans sa vie
parce que ceux qui ont été vraiment
malheureux au moins une fois dans leur
vie ils savent au moins par différence
que le bonheur aussi existent le bonheur
c'est quand on n'est pas malheureux
le bonheur c'est quand la joie est au
moins possible et bien mon ami peintre
dans le deuil que je vivais m'a rappelée
par l'expérience par le spectacle qu'il
me donnait de sa propre joie il m'a
rappelé que la joie continuer à être
possible pour les autres et que donc
sans doute un jour elle redeviendrait
possible pour moi et évidemment c'est ce
qui s'est passé donc le bonheur et la
joie c'est dans la possibilité puisque
dans l'air et dans la réalité
la joie est réelle mais elle n'est pas
toujours réelle et donc il faut d'abord
le bonheur c'est quand la joie est
possible la joie c'est quand la joie est
réel dans cet ouvrage l'inconsolable on
a parlé du premier chapitre d'un console
avait la joie de vivre que vous dédié à
clément rosset on trouve un chapitre
enfin un texte sur beethoven sur jules
laforgue et puis on trouve ce texte sur
l'un de vos maîtres vous l'appelez
l'autre m il s'agit de louis althusser
dont on parle peut-être moins
aujourd'hui qui à l'époque était très
connu will et je ne peux pas savoir que
l'était laura de louis althusser jeudi
l'autre met en pensant à notre med qui
est marché de compte je pense
qu'aujourd'hui marcel conche est au
moins aussi connu quelques serres peut
être plus mais il ya 40 ans quand dd
connu l'un et l'autre est l inverse
quand personne ne connaissait son nom
sorti de la sorbonne et louis althusser
était connu dans le monde entier puisque
tu un penseur marxiste d'obédience
structuraliste comment disait ah
l'époque avec une oeuvre très étroite à
l'époque il n'avait guère de publier au
fond que le petit montesquieu pour marx
et ses contributions à lire le capital
et on lisait ça avec émerveillement
parce que tout d'un coup le marxiste
retrouvait sa sa densité théorique sa
force théorique et actuaire était
étonnamment à la mode enfin c'était le
penseur le plus à la mode dans quoi je
l'avais lu quand j'étais en hypokhâgne
et en can
et quand j'ai frappé à son bureau la
première fois après avoir été reçus à
normale sup
c'était quand même très impressionné
jusqu'à ce qu'on apprenne en 1981 au
journal de tf1
l'information suivante bonsoir l'école
normale supérieure la vénérable maison
de la rue d'ulm en est tout bouleverser
on a du mal à croire aux informations
qui se succèdent depuis ce matin les
pousses du philosophe marxiste louis
althusser a été découverte étranglée
dans son appartement de fonction et
louis althusser
c'est à cusset tout de suite de ce
meurtre il a été conduit à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de sainte anne dans une
crise dans un état de crise aiguë le
philosophe dont la renommée dépasse
largement nos frontières et qui est âgé
de 62 ans souffrait de dépression
nerveuse et de troubles psychiques
depuis plusieurs mois il était
d'ailleurs en congé de maladie depuis le
3 novembre
son épouse âgée de 70 ans était la
secrétaire de l'école normale
la police judiciaire a ouvert une
information pour homicide volontaire et
c'est au cours de l'autopsié qu'on a
constaté la strangulation
le larynx avait été fracturé vous
évoquez cet épisode évidemment dans
votre livre à andré comte sponville il
est difficile de j'imagine de garder
intacts les souvenirs que vous avez de
cette personne après cet événement oui
bien sûr j'étais plus à l'époque élèves
de l'école supérieure de la paix sa part
la radio la télé ou la presse comme tout
le monde ça nous a tous bouleversés par
ce que on est mais s'étonne je les aime
toujours
on est effrayé évidemment par le meurtre
de sa femme objectivement reconnaissant
qu'on avait plus de chagrin pour lui que
pour elle parce que lui on le sait très
bien elle avait à peine croisé quelques
fois dans les couloirs de l'école et
puis au fond mourir c'est le lot commun
à mourir étrangler sa hotte fort
désagréable mais très sa femme
ça nous paraissait affreux et on s'est
dit mais quel malheur pour lui et
effectivement ça a été pour lui un
calvaire au fond parce qu'il aimait
cette femme est alors présenté beaucoup
revu au début il était à sainte anne ne
voyait personne mais quelques années
plus tard quand il a commencé à sortir
de l'hôpital il m'avait écrit pour qu'on
pour concevoir
c'était l'homme le plus malheureux que
que je connaissais à l'époque est l'une
des cours il y avait là le match en lui
même ce qu'il appelait la pierre tombale
du non lieu comme les psychiatres ont
déclaré en état de démence pendant les
faits il n'y a pas eu de procès et donc
du coup ce qu'il appelle la piste qu'il
appelait la pierre tombale du non lieu
c'est que il n'a pas pu être punis et
donc ils les porter toujours en quelque
chose ce boulet d'avoir étranglé sa
femme et puis ton notre chagrin c'est
que sa femme lui manquait atrocement et
donc il était d'un état de solitude
terrible en plus il souffrait depuis des
années d'une psychose maniaco-dépressive
et donc dans les états de dépression il
est atrocement malheureux et les
psychiatres voulait pas trop soigné ses
états dépressifs de peur qu'ils ne
retombent dans un état maniaque où il
était plus dangereux pour les autres et
pour lui-même et donc ça a été pendant
des années enfin jusqu'à sa mort en
vérité l'homme le plus malheureux que
j'ai été amené à fréquenter vous dit de
lui il était inconsolable et me rendais
tel par quoi elle ressemblait à ma mère
qui en étaient mortes ou plutôt car elle
lui ressemblait en rien sauf je le
réalise à l'instant par le prénom elle
s'appelait louise par quoi ils
produisaient sur moi en moi un effets
analogues cellule le premier
inconsolable on apprend que c'est votre
mère wind river aussi en quelque chose
merde c'est vrai que vous dire un mot
sur l'histoire des articles dans un
article qui m'a été commandé au départ
par le figaro pour une série estivale
qu'il faisait sur le thème la personne
qui les a le plus marqués donc ça va
essayer de faire un article
la personne qui m'a le plus marqué qu'il
avait appuyé monette sort était ma mère
effectivement mais je me voyais pas
parler de ma mère sujet trop douloureux
dans les journaux et donc je m'étais
replier si j'ose dire sur althusser
autre sujet de votre mère et je découvre
effectivement que les deux avaient le
même prénom masculin féminin louis
althusser et ma mère s'appelait louis
j'espère que ma mère était aussi en
quelque chose
inconsolable d'aurélie mortelle s'est
suicidé alors là j'étais une trentaine
une trentaine d'années mais
ça m'a aussi éclairé c'est qu'au fond ma
mère n'a jamais supporté que la vie ne
correspondent pas à ses espérances nous
souvient quand j'ai publié mon premier
livre traiter du désespoir et de la
béatitude l'une des premières lettres de
lecteurs que j'ai reçus mme été écrite
par un psychanalyste qui me disait qu'il
était d'accord dans la critique que je
faisais de désillusions de l'espoir
parce que me disait-il en tant que
thérapeute
je constate que l'espérance est la
principale cause de suicide
on ne se tue que par déception nous
disait-il
et ça m'avait frappé parce que des mots
font voilà il a raison maman situé par
déception elle s'est fait parce que
depuis des dizaines d'années
la vie ne correspondait pas aux espoirs
qu'elle s'en était fait eh bien je vais
vous dire la vie ne correspondra jamais
à vos espoirs
l'erreur simplement ses plans la vie ne
correspond pas à nos espoirs certains en
concluent que c'est la vie qui a tort et
donc la logique qui menaçait de se
suicider alors que mon idée bien sûr est
que la ville de fismes a aidé à
comprendre pourquoi je dis souvent que
la philosophie a été ma bonne mère celle
qui a entrepris mme qui m'a aidé à
guérir de la brèque d'une mer très
aimante mais très malheureuse très
pathologique dépressive parce que la
fille m'a aidé à comprendre c'est que
quand la vie ne correspond pas à nos
espoirs c'est pas la vie qui a tort que
certains ne veut rien dire que la vie
est hors la vie et les ce qu'elle ait
fait ce qu'elle peut quand la vie ne
compte pas nos espoirs ça prouve que nos
désespoirs que nos espoirs sont vains
illusoire mensongers et que c'est au
contraire en acceptant de voir la vie
comme elle est en refusant de se
raconter des histoires comme j'ai
toujours louis althusser qu'on va
pouvoir aimer la vie telle qu'elle est
alors althusser qui était vraiment grave
en maladie ya pas tout à fait pas
revenus mais aussi dans ces moments de
lucidité
il avait d'ailleurs cette espèce
d'ouverture d'accueil de l'aude extrême
gentillesse et ça le paradoxe
d'althusser c'est que lui qui écrivait
durement avec une écriture tellement
appuyé vigoureuse presque des voix
caricaturalement structuré dans la vie
privée il était d'une gentillesse d'une
douceur d'une délicatesse extrême
alors il ya un espoir qui ne va pas vous
décevoir aujourd'hui en tout cas andré
comte sponville et c'est celui que vous
avez formulé de rencontrer au cours de
cette émission
la romancière judith brouste je propose
qu'on l'accueille à présent très bonne
hantise
[Musique]
bonjour je deale brouste bonjour
bienvenue dans livres et vous merci
c'était un plaisir de vous y recevoir
alors c'est andré comte sponville qui
vous a convié je suis vraiment ravi de
ce choix vous vous connaissez je crois
je vous laisse nous dire quelle est la
nature de votre ligne en connaître
depuis 25 ans 26 en a fait un livre
ensemble l'époque on se connaissait pas
du tout et d'un éditeur nous devez veut
nous rencontrer
finalement c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé on s'est rencontré en vérifiant la
toute première fois à la signature une
signature en librairie de christian
bobin
mais plus que 10% jeudi les épais est
toujours là me rouler longtemps
connaissait ni sunnites ni christian et
nous avons écrites et entretiens que
l'amour la solitude
c'était en 92 moi je sortais d'un cancer
donc andré m'a proposé cette
collaboration il ça m'a vraiment permis
de revivre un petit peu et de me
replonger dans le
l'écriture et la pensée donc vous diriez
vous aussi que l'écriture la littérature
peut être la philosophie sont propose
des formes de réconfort dans ces cas-là
de réconfort jeu la consolation vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure et la vérité
de la console à ions je crois pas trop à
la consolation je crois qui expliquait
la côte de la souffrance est une forme
de consolation et moi ça ne me va pas
trop mais disons que je n'ai pas le
la carrière d'andré moi je n'ai pas fait
d'études du tout je suis autodidacte
donc penser réfléchir m'a aidé
effectivement à surmonter la souffrance
mais à ne pas l'oublier
vous vous dites expliqué la souffrance
et ce pour quoi vous écrivez c'est pour
mettre des mots dessus
non c'est la comprendre et puis c'est la
transforme et surtout je crois que
l'écriture métamorphose les choses et
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
normaux livre c'est à dire que l'enfance
on l'a reconstruit on l'a on l'a on la
transforme on l'a métabolise et je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait une vérité de
l'enfance votre livre s'appelle
l'enfance futur il est moins lié chez
gallimard et n'y voit un récit peut être
autobiographique en tout cas qui met en
scène une petite fille qui découvre le
journal de son père un journal que son
parent a tenu pendant les premières
années de sa propre vie et elle va
revisiter son enfance à travers les
phrases que son père a écrite à ce
moment là alors qu'elles ignoraient tout
de ce journal absolument elle a été
écrite
si je peux dire j'ai été manipulé d'une
certaine façon je suis devenu écrivain
quand j'avais neuf ans donc c'est vous
là vous dites je la sais mieux matrix
qui parle la narratrice jamais eu
catherine qui s'appelle catherine est le
vrai prénom de judith a alors ça y a que
vous qui prouve je dit s'appeler
catherine quand elle était petite fille
est donc ça renforce quand même
sensiblement la dimension
autobiographique du tout ça oui enfin
l'autobiographie ouais je sais pas s'il
ya une vérité dans l'autobiographie je
crois pas qu'il ya une vérité dans la
biographie non plus
on reconstruit les choses et on
s'imagine son enfance à l'origine c'est
un petit peu le lien à la mer c'est pas
forcément que le lien à la mer l'origine
ces lieux le lien à l'histoire dans
laquelle on est né c'est ce que je
raconte dans le livre chacun né à une
certaine période un certain moment et de
l'avis des parents bien sûr mais de
l'avis du monde aussi c'est à dire qu'il
ya eu une interpénétration je crois que
l'enfant est réceptif à tout ce qui se
passe autour de lui aux informations
même si à l'époque elle n'était qu'à la
radio ces informations puisqu'il n'y
avait pas la télévision dans les années
50 pas encore mais je crois qu'on entend
et on écoute tout ce qui se passe dans
le monde et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans
tous mes livres c'est à dire 7 7 7 à
pénétration 7 entre l'histoire et son
histoire
c'est ça parce que j'ai présenté le
roman en disant que c'est une fille qui
découvre le journal de son père j'aurais
pu dire c'est un roman sur la guerre
d'indochine enfin il ya les deux
histoires qui se mêlent dans ce texte où
se mêlent oui tout se mêle il ya un lien
qui se fait et elle est à l'écouté de ce
lien et dès l'enfance et toute sa vie
finalement on étale écoute des liens qui
se tissent en soi et autour de soi donc
ce livre raconte l'écho qu'elle entend
ce sont toujours des échos c'est pour ça
que la vérité
simone veil disait que la vérité c'est
supporter le vide et que supporter le
vide c'est accepter la mort est la
vérité du côté de la mort le philosophe
la philosophe bien qu'un double verrou
avec un w donc on est du côté de la mort
là dès l'enfance
dès l'enfance est petite fille est
confrontée à la guerre donc à la mort
donc à une certaine forme de 10 réalité
finalement parce que c'est irréel tout
ça rien n'existe pour elle ne sait pas
qui est ce qu il réel et ce qui n'est
pas le réel
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans l'écriture
de judith brouste andré comte sponville
déjà ça l'hésitation entre le réel et
l'irréel c'est du réel et pourtant il ya
un effet d'étrangeté un mort ça t la
première chose l'autre chose c'est que
judith non seulement est une femme libre
je pense que c'est la femme la plus
libre que je connaisse et elle a une
écriture extrêmement tenue rigoureuse a
quasi acétique et qui a même pas et très
poétique et ça j'aime beaucoup ça attire
t de la prose il n'y a pas du tout de
rhétorique ya pas un poil de graisse et
il ya une espèce de poésie mystérieuse
parce qu'on demande à quoi ça tient
justement cette espèce de réel qui n'est
pas vraiment un qui est troublant comme
un rêve et qui pourtant n'est pas n'est
pas un rêve est donc ce contraste la
entre ce qu'elle est face aux
contraintes c'est pas pour ça c'est pas
une contradiction mais entre la liberté
de la femme qu'elle est et la rigueur de
l'est quasi ascétique de l'écriture
moi je trouve ça formidable est ce que
vous y retrouver l'inconsolable qui vous
oui mais là on échange trois idées on
s'est rencontré lors d'une signature de
christian bobin en pointe et rameau
christian judith c'est le jour et la
nuit
christian et du côté du jour sur il se
réveille le matin tout est lumineux tout
est beau parfois un peu trop pour notre
goût judith un tel que je le vois
elle est plus du côté de la nuit si vous
voulez donc elle est du côté
effectivement de dole inconsolable et je
pense que je suis un petit peu entre les
deux t'as pas dire que j'ai raison et
même l'un et l'autre pour elle deux
points vim
leur procès mais ça veut dire que tout
tempérament je partage le côté un peu
mélancolique de judith mais je préfère
quand même aller du côté où il ya un peu
de lumière comme je crois je le disais
tout à l'heure et c'est vrai que ce
qu'il ya de lumineux c'est christian
bobin me séduit aussi mais elle
effectivement plutôt du côté de de
l'inconsolable de vivre c'est-à-dire du
tragique finalement le tragique et on
peine spirituels quotidiens chose de
très beaux dans le livre d'andré c'est
quand eddie montagne n'aurais pas écrit
les essais s'il n'avait pas eu la mort
de la boétie donc la boétie qui était
son meilleur a dit cette phrase et ses
célèbres parce que c'était lui parce que
cette première à celui ci meurt et
montaigne proprement inconsolable il
écrit des textes mais il y avait
toujours un gain au chagrin finalement
le chagrin la souffrance apporte quelque
chose de l'intérêt de la nourriture
c'est la souffrance qui nous nourrit
c'est pour ça que l'écriture évidemment
n'est dans ces lieux obscurs dont vous
parlez dont tu parles et qui sont un peu
mystérieuse souterrain même du domaine
du surnaturel
je pense que les plus grands philosophes
sont évidemment des poètes à odeur linde
et novalis sont pour moi les plus grands
philosophes du monde mais vous n'avez
pas renoncer la lumière puisque vous
écrivez puisque vous lisez puisque vous
aimez la littérature c'est quand même le
signe de d'un cheminement vers le palais
dans la lumière mais dans une lumière de
là d'une vérité en quête d'une vérité
cette vague de pureté voilà de pureté
oui la pureté des mots du style de la
phrase c'est vrai ce que dit andré c'est
à dire que la liberté de la vie
je pense que la vie n'est pas l'écriture
c'est différent pour moi vous distinguer
la vie telle que vous l'avez la vie
telle que vous l'écrivez oui oui et dans
votre texte vous raconter comment vous
avez découvert votre propre vie d'enfant
écrite par votre père ben voilà ce
qu'était une violence dans dés le départ
non seulement il ya une violence mais il
ya aussi une ambiguïté une sorte de
mensonges et pourquoi une violence parce
qu'on pourrait on pourrait voir ce geste
là comme étant un signe d'attention du
père envers sa fille il faut dire que
dans le texte il ya le père ne parle pas
de sa fille en termes élogieux
parce que j'avais violent voilà si
violent et puis il veut imposer son
diktat
il veut avoir une fille comme il a envie
qu'elle soit et la fit une rebelle dès
le départ donc
elle s'oppose évidemment opère dans la
mesure de ses moyens qui sont des petits
moyens parce que quand on est enfant on
a toujours des petits moyens on croit
qu'on a des petits moyens en fait on a
des très grands moyens parce que les
yeux de l'enfant perse la nuit ce que je
dis
voilà donc les yeux de l'enfant sont
souvent extraordinaires et comment avez
vous choisi de décrire à votre tour
puisque cette écriture de votre père
vous attend blessés vous êtes pourtant
vous même devenu écrivain c'était pour
raconter votre vie à travers vos mots je
ne sais pas si j'ai choisi du coup parce
que le guide ma g et écrite dès le
départ donc j'ai repris cette chose pour
ne pas être manipulés à mon tour il ne
dira moi je vais aussi écrire ce que je
suis puisqu'il a écrit ce que j'étais
il a écrit ce que j'étais et moi j'ai
voulu écrire ce que je suis et ce que
est ce qu un peu maintenant dans ce
propre livre ce que j'ai été mais vous
n'avez pas d'emblée choisi la forme
romanesque que vous avez écrit la poésie
je crois j'ai commencé à écrire des
poèmes quand je suis arrivé à paris
je les vendais aux terrasses des cafés
j'écrivais de la poésie oui mais il
avait fondé une maison d'édition jamais
maison d'édition avec philippe
thureau-dangin où nous avons plutôt
publié des textes politiques
donc tous mes livres je dirais ce sont
quand même axé sur le politique c'est à
dire qu'il ya quelque chose dans la
guerre d'indochine
il ya quelque chose aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup du postcolonial on est dans le
post coloniale là on était dans le monde
colonial puisque c'est la première une
des premières vraies guerres coloniales
qui était très loin mais qui avait un
impact formidable en france tous les
journaux tous les jours
raconter l'histoire de cette guerre des
victoires des défaites et du stade
terminal si je peux dire qui a été d une
benne fou qui a été une sorte de débâcle
totale et pour l'armée et pour la france
donc moi bien sûr j'étais du côté
vietminh j'ai tout de suite adhéré à ces
gens qu'ils se rebellaient qui se
battaient pour leur liberté et les jours
ce qui est très ambivalents et très
curieux c'est que les gens qui avaient
fait la deuxième guerre mondiale pour
libérer la france
ils sont partis en indochine contre la
liberté
il ya là une ambiguïté une ambivalence
delente delattre à libérer l'alsace
il a libéré la france et il est parti en
indochine
non pas pour libérer mais pour repris
mais les vietnamiens et les leviers de
kong
donc là il ya une sorte de paradoxe
comment ces gens là ne se sont pas posé
des questions en dix ans mais nous les
libérateurs nous sommes devenus les
oppresseurs et vous mettez ça en miroir
avec votre propre sort puisque les deux
histoires figure dans le même texte
évidemment c'est la droite qui est l
oppresseur de même que ses autres
personnes et les parents d'une certaine
façon sont toujours les oppresseurs
permis que oui il va l'imposer
ce qui sont leurs lois leurs
ce qui explique mes deux exergue de
sartre que gêné au début du livre
j'ai donc je pense que ça très explique
parle très bien de ça dans les mots par
exemple c'est à dire qu'on on est on est
en butte à la famille d'une façon ou
d'une autre
andré comte sponville les parois sont
toujours des oppresseurs pas tous à tout
cas pas tous de la même passion mais ce
qui me frappe en écoutant judée de
séquelles à la fois inconsolable et
irréconciliables c'est à dire que avec
elle même ou avec qui n'ont avec le
monde de la guerre d'indochine à 8 ans
elle a pris le parti du viet congs
quelques dizaines d'années plus tard
elle ne bougera pas d'un iota
moi qui ai quelques années de moins
qu'avec mes calculs la guerre du vietnam
quand saigon est tombé ça a été l'un des
jours les plus heureux de ma vie c'était
pas vietnam à l'époque c'était l'un des
chiens de cheminots c'est bien on parle
pas de la même terre mais c'est que j'ai
déjà les quelques années de moins que
toi mais quand ça qu'on est tombé
c'était l'un des jours les plus heureux
de ma vie
aujourd'hui je fais pas certain qu'au
fond ce jour là et étaient si heureux
que ça joue aucune sympathie pour le
vietnam du sud mais quand on sait ce qui
s'est passé quand on sait ce qu'elles
viennent du nord
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai dit écrit aussi à
propos des attentats de l'automne 2015 à
paris alors j'aime beaucoup ce côté
irréconciliables de judith c'est vrai
que moi j'ai tendance mais peut-être
parce que je suis philosophe a essayé
davantage de deux de comprendre de
relativiser
et donc je ne venaient plus aujourd'hui
les mêmes positions que j'avais quand
j'avais 16 ou 17 ans alors que judith
amtrak beaucoup la femme qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
au fond a les mêmes positions les mêmes
jugements que la petite fille qu'elle
décrit dans son lit c'est ce que
j'appelle la dimension il réconciliant
mais la dimension politique pour le coup
ce n'est pas nos culs pas une place très
importante dans votre oeuvre
andré comte sponville ta dépendance est
l'oeuvre coûte un livre intimiste pas du
tout dans d'autres 2010 tient davantage
mais c'est vrai que je pense pas que le
philosophe soit là pour donner des
leçons au monde entier
non mais pour aider à le comprendre pour
des le comprendre mais voilà c'est un
livre sur le capitaliste dont je pense
qu'ils aident à comprendre ce fait il me
dit ça m'oblige pas à faire une pétition
pour dire pour qui voter voilà pour moi
la frontière et là un livre de philippe
mais je disais pas ça mais le feu n'a
fait là pour essayer d'aider à
comprendre pour prendre du recul et donc
prendre du recul ça veut dire ne pas
rajouter de la colère à la colère de la
haine à la n 20 de mes amis que judith
connais bien mais me reproche de ne pas
poussé un grand cri
tu disais que les grands cris sont
rarement très intelligent et le rôle
d'un philosophe effectivement c'est
d'essayer d'apporter un peu de recul un
peu d'intelligence il le peut un peu de
données qu'on est en recul et 17
intelligent et c'est pourquoi j'écris
très régulièrement dans la presse et sur
tille des recueils d'articles plus
politique que j'appelle non pas des
impromptus
mais des propos c'est pas du tout le
même genre mais voilà l'impromptu pour
moi parce que c'est l'esprit de schubert
c'est de la philosophie intimiste où
j'essaye de penser au plus près de ce
que je suis comme individu est donc
effectivement un peu plus loin du monde
que dans d'autres textes victoire ils
vous disaient je n'écris pas je pousse
un cri
voilà vous vous reconnaissez dans cette
formule oui je crois qu'il ya quelque
chose du cri du de la pulsion aussi dans
l'écriture
quelque chose qui sort de soin céline
disait on met ses tripes sur la table il
ya quelque chose au site comme ça je
voulais dire aussi que s'il ya eu
beaucoup de livres et de films sur la
guerre du vietnam
les américains ont beaucoup écrit et
fait deux films il ya eu très peu de
choses sur l'indochine
y compris dans les films à part les
films de schoendoerffer et de livres qui
ont été écrits sur l'indochine
l'amérique vraiment fait son miel de
cette guerre les français l'ont occulter
parce que pourquoi parce qu'elle fait
honte parce qu'elle nous a fait don de
cette guerre dès le départ et l arrivée
encore bien davantage l avion tout
américain aussi cela
oui mais peut-être qu'ils se mettent
davantage devant leur propre histoire je
pense qu'on a du mal nous au cinéma
c'est vrai en tout cas nous à se mettre
devant les faits de l'histoire vous
dites d'ailleurs dans votre livre
appartient à propos des attentats du
bataclan la porte de la chambre qui
gardaient l'accès de l'ancienne guerre
s'ouvre à nouveau
catherine la narratrice renaît avec le
tumulte des tueries et des massacres
ben oui comme quelque chose qui se
rejoue à nouveau et c'est l'actualité
qui fait écho à la guerre passée votre
propre oui parce que rien ne ressemble
plus à une guerre qu n'est qu'une autre
guerre les guerres et toujours le
massacre la mort l'horreur bon alors on
a revécu ça effectivement en 2015 à
l'époque où moi je terminais l'écriture
de ce livre donc ça m'a énormément
bousculer de retrouver et c'est à ce
propos que j'ai retrouvé quelque chose
de l'enfance et de la violence de la
haine du monde andré comte sponville non
mais j'écoute mieux passé à la formule
de victor hugo disant que voilà victor
hugo est un immense poète n'était pas un
philosophe voilà moi j'essaie de ma foi
ça qu'on fait ce qu'il veut mais et
c'est de rajouter un peu de complexité
et les crises ont tous dit on peut
s'inscrire
elle allume une exacte je n'écris pas je
crie pour 5
les crises ont toujours simplificateur
et je crois que notre monde est à pout
beaucoup troll à la simplification et
que le rôle d'un intellectuel c'est pas
de rajouter du simplisme ou simpliste
c'est rajouter un peu de nuance un peu
de complexification à un peu de recul un
peu de distance alors c'est peut-être
moins gratifiant que de pousser un grand
cri l'autre j'ai assez crier dans ma
jeunesse pour préférer aujourd'hui un
peu plus de discrétion
mais le cri peut-être maîtrise et
peut-être à partir du moment où il est
écrit secrecy écrire le cri voilà en
nuances à sortir du moment où on relit
cris évidemment on le transforme et il
ya une rigueur qui d'ailleurs a
justement la voie puisque je vous ai
demandé à l'un et à l'autre de venir
avec vos trois livres de chevet des
livres qui ont compté pour vous vous
citiez hugo le voici voire d'un crime
histoire d'un crime alors mais pas les
ouvrages plus connus de victor hugo
nyamé si le texte extraordinaire qui le
lemay en exil c'est le texte évidemment
qui est écrit après le coup d'état du 2
décembre 1851 il est dans les rues de
paris
c'est un texte extraordinaire parce que
c'est un texte qui raconte l'errance
d'hugo dans les rues de paris et les
barricades avec celle cher faubourg
saint-antoine
donc c'est son expérience et en même
temps c'est un texte politique parce
qu'ils racontent l'arrivée cette arrivée
effrayante pour lui de napoli ce qui
sera plus tard napoléon iii et
évidemment il est mis en exil
il est obligé de partir quand on a écrit
un livre comme ça on ne peut plus vivre
en france il part il revient en soixante
dix et en 71 y réécrit la fin de son
livre qui se termine par sedan c'est à
dire par l'échec de napoléon
c'est un livre magnifique
x est un cri il ya une écriture violente
et mer magnifique et nuancée j'en suis
sûr sans les deux autres alors le 2e est
le 2ème sebald austerlitz la vie de
jacques austerlitz est aussi un auteur
qui revient aux origines avec une ville
dabiri thê vinh amir habilité secrète
donc il parle de ses origines et en même
temps il en fait quelque chose de
politique sur les migrants sur l'exil le
troisième texte et vous l'aviez rumeurs
sur mon imac veille la pesanteur et la
grâce qu'elle écrit en 42 après son
séjour à londres où elle a rejoint la
france libre
après avoir travaillé dans les usines et
elmer un an plus tard
n'est ce pas donc c'est un peu la menthe
du malheur mais c'est un texte
extraordinaire ce qui relie ces trois
livres
c'est le fil de l'histoire c'est à dire
que ces trois livres sont connectés à
l'événement à l'expérience et à
l'histoire
merci beaucoup en tout cas vous avez
envie de les lier merci pour andré comte
sponville vous avez quatre livres oui le
dit non par marianne2 je m'excuse
l'extrême banalité donc monteyne les
essais dont il faut que peut-être dia
malgré tout que c'est la première fois
qu'un livre ça plaît et c'est à l'époque
n'est pas un genre littéraire c'est un
titre le titre d'un livre pourquoi et
c'est parce qu'il essaye d'écrire trop
grave que ça va donner dans le geste
même il créé un nouveau genre qu'on
appelle maintenant les essais dans le
monde entier et il s'installe
définitivement au sommet du genre qu'il
vient de créer ce qui est un cas sans
précédent est d'ailleurs sans son
successeur deuxième modèle les pensées
de pascal ont cassé en deux tomes de
l'édition chez folio gallimard qu al
avantage de finale pour les amateurs
d'avoir un index très bien fait sinon il
ya d'autres éditions qui équivalent
celle ci c'est d'oeuvre absolu en plus
je préférais évidemment ressembler à
monteils mais de tempérament je suis
beaucoup plus proches malheureusement de
pascal de même que ce prix devrait
ressembler mozart et que malheureusement
je suis beaucoup plus proche de
beethoven effet troisièmement pour aller
vite bas l'un des plus grands livres de
philosophie de tous les temps l'éthique
de spinoza
alors disons quand même téléspectateurs
que ce troisième livre est un livre très
difficile qu'il faut faire deux autres
qui sont dans la merde ces deux défauts
est un peu difficile à cause de la
langue qui habillés tout pourquoi je
conseille de lire dans une édition
l'orthographe et modernité par une
traduction mais ça peut que
l'orthographe soit modernisée pascal ne
pose aucun problème de compréhension de
compréhension voilà ce sont trois ans il
faut s'accrocher mais ça vaut vraiment
la peine trois vols c'est évidemment
l'un des venir des dix plus grands
livres de philosophie de tous les temps
évidemment je pense que tous mes
collègues seraient d'accord
et puis même si on ne comprend pas tout
comme c'est écrit mme moret géométrie qu
avec des petits à la façon des géomètres
donc avec des axiomes des définitions
des propositions on peut plonger dedans
un peu au hasard et on en tire a quand
même quelque chose pour être fidèle à
ses lectures impromptues dirons nous
voici un extrait d'un an prompte eu de
schubert justement vous le citez dans
votre nom votre ouvrage entre et qu'on
se profile ecoutez-le peut-être
allez-vous le reconnaître
il
c'est peut-être là on se retrouve la
joie dans la musique
oui mais voilà schubert console bien ce
sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup de réponses pour village
et a accroché introduit il fallait pas
venir sur la consommation on finira donc
sur l'inquiétude ou les deux merci à
tous les deux d'être venu aux gentianes
à bientôt jusqu'à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre
[Musique]